la última hora es que la evacuación de
la ciudad de mariupol ha sido
interrumpida por la falta de garantías
por parte de rusia de que cumplirá con
el cese al fuego es lo que ha informado
la misma alcaldía de mariupol sin
embargo como pueden ver detrás nuestro
continúa el éxodo de personas de otras
partes del país de ucrania un éxodo que
va hacia el oeste y hacia la frontera
con la unión europea un éxodo que está
haciendo también muy difícil porque el
viaje en sí está siendo complicado con
atascos y momentos en que realmente
avanzamos a paso de hombre es una
situación desesperante para estas
personas que están huyendo de las bombas
rusas y que ahora se encuentran también
en esta ruta desorientado sobre que
acontecerá con su vida en los próximos
días y en las próximas semanas